الجديد باننا الان داخل هذا المطار وداخل
القاعده العسكريه العملياتيه في مدينه
مروي هذا هو برج المراقبه الرئيس للقاعده
وللمطار هذا البرج الذي كنا يوم امس في
هذه النقطه وقد عاكسنا حجم الضرر الذي لحق
به الان سنحاول ان نقترب اكثر عبر هذا
البث الحصري لقناه العربيه لمعرفه تفاصيل
ما حدث وحجم الضرر الذي لحق بهذا الجزء من
المطار وبالقاعده العسكريه العملياتيه
هذا الامر الان كما نتابع الان حجم للضرر
في هذه القاعده نحن الان سنقترب اكثر
نحن الان نصعد الى الدرجات العليا لهذا
البرج
وهو برج المراقبه الرئيس لهذا المطار الذي
يمتد لي عدد من الطوابق
كثير من الاضرار لحقت بهذا البرج الذي
يعول عليه كثيرا في العمليات الملاحيه
الجويه
هذا البرج خالد خلال الايام الماضيه كان
تحت محطه النيران نتيجه للاشتباكات التي
كانت متواصله في هذا الجزء
وفي هذه المنطقه
من القاعده العسكريه كل الصور الان التي
تشاهدها هي من داخل هذا البرج
نحن الان في مناطق عليا
من هذا البرج
الذي تضرر بحسب نفادات خاصه
لمدير المطار والان نشاهد
هذه هي بعض الطلقات
الناريه او الطلقات الاسلحه هذا الضرر
لهذا البرج
تشاهد الان
ايضا حجم الضرر في هذه المناطق
وصل اليها هذا البرج
ضرر كثير لحقت بالاجهزه هذه بعض الاجهزه
الفنيه التي تستخدم هنا في اطار العمليات
الملاحيه الجويه
ايضا تاثرت
نحاول ايضا ان نصعد اكثر
لمعرفه التفاصيل
واستجلاء المعلومه عن حجم الضرر عبر الصوت
والصوره وعبر البث الحي
ما زلنا داخل برج
المراقبه هذه اجهزه فنيه
اخبرونا انها
على درجه عاليه من الحساسيه
اجهزه تقنيه
ايضا تاثرت وتضررت
كما تشاهدون الان في هذه الصور
الخاصه لقناه العربيه
نمضي الان الى اعلى
الى المقر الرئيسي للبرج
هنا تدار كل العمليات الفنيه
والعمليات الاستراتيجيه لعمليه الملاحه
الجويه
هذه الاجهزه اكيزه التواصل والاتصال
يبدو انها مدمره بالكامل
واستقبال الطائرات
عبر اجهزه الرادر محمد بالنسبه
هنا هذه الصور لهذه الاجهزه اللاسلكيه
يبدو انها خارج الخدمه مع من الان
كالنتيجه اشتباكات حصلت في هذه المواقع ام
تدمير للعناصر الدعم السريع ربما التي
كانت موجوده قبل انسحابها ماذا يقول
هو مؤكد خالد
المطروحه الان بان الاشتباكات كانت عنيفه
كل ما يحدث من ضرر هو نتيجه لهذا
الاشتباكات نتيجه للقصف العنيف الذي شهدته
هذه المنطقه
هذا ما يمكن ان نؤكد عليه بان الضرر وقع
نتيجه لعمل عسكري كانت هذه المنطقه من
المطار
مسرحا
وكانت ارضيه لكل العمليات العسكريه القصف
المدفعي القصف العنيف
حجم الضرر هذا الدمار الذي لحق بالمطار
لحق بالقاعده
لحق بهذا البرج لهذه القاعده وهذا المطار
الذي يمثل احد اهم المطارات في المنطقه
الاقليميه لانه يطل على الاتجاه الشمالي
للسودان على حدود السودان مع دوله مصر
منهم مباشره يمكن ان يتم التنسيق كما فعل
مسبقا الجيش السوداني مع عدد من جيوش
الدول في المنطقه الاقليميه
ايضا يعتبر هذا المطار بديلا لمطار
الخرطوم الدولي اذا ما حدثت اي متغيرات في
مطار الخرطوم يتم الاستعانه بهذا المطار
عليه فان برج المراقبه يمثل اولويه في ان
يستعاد
عبر التوفير كل ما من شانه ان يسمح لهذا
البرج ان يعاود عمله وان تستكمل الاجهزه
التي
دمرت خلال الاشتباكات الاخيره
يبدو خالد بان هذا هو ما سمح به الوقت
وعكس كل ما يدور الان في هذه القاعده التي
وصلنا الى قمه الهرم هرم المراقبه فيها
وتابعنا حجم الضرر الذي لحق به المستندات
ولحق بالادوات المكتبيه ولحق به ديسك
المعلومات الخاص بالعمليات الجويه التي
كانت تدور في هذه المنطقه
للعمل وللخدمه لن يكون في وقت
قصير ربما هل هناك اي ضرر وقع على مدرج
المطار الذي انتهبطه تقلع منه الطائرات
ايضا
مدرج المطار مدرج المطار الذي يمتد لي نحو
اربعه كيلومترات لم يتاثر بصوره مباشره
ولكن الضرر هو ضرر جزئي كما اكد مسؤولون
هنا بمطار مروي الدولي جل الضرر خالد هو
يتعلق ببرج المراقبه والاليات التي تعاون
هذا المطار على العمل والاجهزه الحساسه
اجهزه المراقبه الجويه هي من تاثر المرافق
الحيويه تاثرت تدرك تماما بان مثل هذه
المواقع الاستراتيجيه الاجهزه المتعلقه
بالاتصالات وبالمراقبه وبتبادل المعلومات
هي من الحساسيه ومن الاهميه بمكان اي ضرر
يقع على هذه الاجهزه وهذه المعدات وهذه
الاليات الفنيه سيعقد صعوبه ان يعود
المطار ليعمل بكفاءته لكن
مختصون ايضا واداره هذا المطار ذكرت لنا
يوم الامس بانهم يعملون الان على حجم او
على حصر الاضرار وعلى رفع تقييم اولي يدفع
به مباشره الى الجهات المختصه في الخرطوم
لمعرفه المدى الزمني والامكانيات الماديه
المتطلب توفرها حتى يعود هذا المطار الى
عمله كما كان سابقا
لنا ان نتحرك من من البرج المراقبه الى
مناطق اخرى اذا اذا كان بامكانك ذلك نزار
لنتعرف اكثر على حجم الدمار الذي حل
باقسام في
المطار وهلنا نتعرف يعني على مدى اهميه
هذا المطار يعني الحجم الضرر الواقع على
الناس التي كانت تستفيد من هذا المطار بعد
تعطله الان
يعني قد لا اجد زمن للتجوال في كل اجزاء
المطار ولكن هذه هي
الظرفيه الوقتيه التي سمحت لنا بان نكون
في هذا الجزء المعلومات المتوفره الان عن
حجم الضرر في هذا المطار هي معلومات تؤكد
ان الضرر كان ضررا جزئيا في كثير من
المحاور وفي كثير من المرافق وكان ضررا
كليا في عدد من المواقع المتعلقه
بالخدمات الملاحيه كما ذكرنا على سبيل
المثال برج المراقبه الذي تاثرت تاثرا
مباشرا بهذه العمليات والاشتباكات ايضا
خالد رصدنا يوم الامس ورصدنا اليوم بان
هنالك ضرر ايضا لحق به السيارات المعينه
لمطار مروي الدولي وهي سيارات الدفاع
المدني هذه السيارات تاثرت ايضا بشكل كلي
في بعض النواحي وبشكل جزئي
الكنترول او اداره السيارات الدفاع المدني
ايضا تاثرت هنالك بعض الصهاريج الوقود
تاثرت ايضا
بالاشتباكات هذه الصهااريت كانت تقع في
الجهه التي كانت توجد بها قوات الدعم
السريع ايضا
علمنا بان الاسعافات اللي كانت التي كانت
موجوده في مطار مروي الدولي هي الان اختفت
ليست موجوده هذا ايضا يشير الى حجم الضرر
الذي لحق بهذا المطار ولحق بهذا المرفق
الاستراتيجي
الذي وجد نفسه جزءا من عمليه عسكريه بدات
في هذا المطار ثم امتدت لتشمل عدد من
المناحي وعدد من المدن في السودان لكن
الان الذي يقال حول هذا الضرر وحول ما حدث
في مطار مروي الدولي بانه نتيجه لما حدث
خلال الايام الماضيه الوضع بعمومياته كان
ملتبسا وكان معقدا القصف الجوي حتى
المواطنون لم يستطيعوا ان يستبينوا الموقف
ويتعرف على وضعيه ابنائهم في هذه القاعده
وفي هذا المطار الا بعد مرور ايام عديده
حتى انجل الامر وحتى بسطت القوات المسلحه
السودانيه سيطرتها على عموم المطار
واستطاعت اتيام وفرق السلاح المهندسين ان
تبدا في عمليه حصر الاضرار والتعامل مع
الاجسام الغير منفجره للذخائر والدانات
التي تم استخدامها بكثافه هنا داخل هذا
المطار شكرا جزيلا لك من مطار مروي
العربيه نزار بقداوي لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات